Too often teams and organizations are unclear about the goals or top priorities really are.
Coaches and players are simply not on the same page.
What you get is everyone just kind of running around in all directions,...
...instead of working together toward the same goal.
The inability to take high-level goals and strategies of an organization...
...and then to translate those into action is a major problem in most organizations.
It's one thing to come up with great strategies and goals,...
...but it's quite another to actually get them done.
This is what we can call "The Execution Gap."
In a landmark study done by the Harris Poll group,...
...we discovered some revealing statistics as to why execution breaks down...
...and why goals aren't translated into action on the front line.
First finding, only 15 percent of those surveyed...
...can actually identify their organization's most important goals or top priorities.
Either there are too many goals or they change too often or they simply don't have any.
And in most cases, they are vastly under communicated.
Just because the leaders are clear on what they want to achieve, it doesn't necessarily mean...
...that the front line where the action really happens knows what the goals are.
After all, in a very real sense, the front line produces the bottom line.
Second, people may know what the goals are but too often they haven't bought into them.
Only 19 percent surveyed say that they feel passionate about the top goals of their organizations.
That's only one in five.
There are number of reasons for this.
But the primary one is that they feel no ownership.
They don't feel that they have input into what is going to take to achieve the goal.
They simply aren't emotionally connected to the goal.
No involvement, no commitment.
Third, those surveyed reported that they spend only 49 percent of their available work hours...
...on the most important goals.
The rest of the time is spent on urgent, but far less important activities.
They get so distracted by urgent things that they neglect the most important things.
Finally, people might know what the goals and top priorities are.
They might even buy into them.
But they don't know what they are supposed to do about them.
In fact, 51 percent state that they personally do not understand what they...
...are supposed to do to help the organization achieve its goals.
Goals will not be executed until everyone clearly understands what the goal is...
...and what they themselves specifically need to do to meet that goal.
Once people are clear on what the goal is, then and only then,...
...are they free to try new and better ways to reach that goal.
So the point is, to achieve goals you've never achieved before,...
...you simply need to start doing things you've never done before.